because you didn't know how an audience
has well over doubled in just the last
couple of years and it's not because we
suddenly became a hit it's because our
podcast numbers are way up and the other
thing is the YouTube community has
discovered us we're now in the top 1% of
all youtubers and we just had our 1
billionth minute of our content
downloaded on YouTube one billionth
minute that's how big a deal we are on
YouTube it's pretty crazy now what comes
with that is of course that audience is
much younger than some of you listening
to AM radio right it's it's a bunch of
puppies a bunch of kiddos and so I get
some of the most interesting stuff on
Twitter now my hate mail has completely
changed and so I I you know you Dave
you're such an old-fashioned
stick-in-the-mud boomer yeah you got it
which is why you're listening so let's
continue that discussion from a minute
ago since I'm an old fashioned
stick-in-the-mud boomer and I hate all
your religious stuff Dave that's the
other one you know I'd listen to you all
the time but all that Bible stuff man
you're just you just you should leave
all that out it doesn't get anything to
do with money you don't know what you're
talking about
right right all right yeah well you're
22 and live in your mother's basement
okay so let's just keep that in mind
who's confused here all right now let's
walk through it though here's an
interesting thing okay professor bill
gals Galston he was on President
Clinton's Domestic Policy Committee he
was one of the advisors found in
research that if you graduate from high
school marry before having a child to
have that child after age 20 this piece
of research says only 8% of the people
who do so will be below the poverty
level fail to do it in that sequence and
79% will be below the poverty line
having babies while you're in high
school having babies very very young
having babies while you're not married
all of these kinds of things it changes
your probability for poverty
dramatically dramatically here's another
one recent report on this topic focusing
on millennials reports that 97% 97% of
those who follow this the success
sequence and here's the sequence earn at
least a high school diploma work and
marry before having children are living
together will not be poor as they enter
their 30s ninety seven percent so I mean
this is just statistical data which is
pretty agnostic except for its
conclusions only four percent of homes
with a married mother and father are on
food stamps at any given time but
twenty-one percent of those cohabitating
and twenty-eight percent of single
parents are on food stamps seventy eight
percent of married people own their own
home 41 percent shacking up cohabitating
adults on their own home so this data
says that you're not winning when you
get these old fashioned moral things out
of order the data says that it's
affecting your life when you just do
whatever the flip you want to do and so
really be thinking about this and moms
and dads really be coaching your kids on
this it affects the probability of
poverty it affects the probability of
financial success well Dave I don't like
you discussing all this Bible stuff
that's not Bible stuff that's research
now the bible does have a lot to say
about these things and i do talk about
biblical finance and i am very open
about the fact that i'm a christian and
there's a reason i I do that it also has
an intellectual basis to it let's well
through that for those of you pups that
don't understand this stuff or that are
just twisted boundary and you're old I
don't care but um here's the deal
personal finance is 80 percent behavior
it's only 20 percent had knowledge the
knowledge the details of what you need
to do to become wealthy and handle money
well are not rocket science live on less
than you make get on a written plan
invest stay out of debt have money saved
for an emergency
don't sign debt for somebody else coke
co-signing these are real basic
primitive concepts they're not deep at
all knowing what to do is like losing
weight most people know what to do but
we like chocolate-chip cookies which are
not conducive to losing weight I have
found personally so especially when you
eat an entire line of them you know so
um the point here is personal finance is
more about changing and managing your
behaviors being emotionally mature than
it is about some set of head knowledge
the secrets of the rich is that there's
not a secret it's self discipline it's
saying I'm not gonna spend like I'm in
Congress I'm not gonna try to keep up
with the Joneses on Instagram because
they are really broke the old Jones is
next door used to be broke the ones on
Instagram are really broke and so I'm
not you know this is behavior management
so here's the thing 100 percent of your
behavior choices are based in your
beliefs what you believe about your
future about life about relationships
about what you believe causes you to
make the behavior choices you make well
I don't want to work all my life and
have no funds I'm gonna go ahead and
have fun now that's a belief and that
causes you to say thank God it's Friday
oh god it's Monday
the little man can't get ahead that's a
belief and if you believe that the whole
game is rigged and no matter what you do
you will not be able to win why would
you work hard to win why would you
sacrifice to win that's a belief beliefs
affect your behaviors your behaviors
flow out of what you believe and what
you believe about right and wrong what
you believe about morals what you
believe about how you treat other people
is a spiritual thing now you can be
Muslim you could be Jewish you can be
agnostic or atheist but your moral code
wherever it comes from is a spiritual
thing
so for someone like me who believes in
God and believes that the Bible is
instructing us on how to live well that
the Scriptures are for our benefit then
some for me to not integrate that into
creating behaviors that cause you to win
would be intellectually dishonest to be
an incomplete picture and so you know I
wish there was a Dave Ramsey that wasn't
religious well they wouldn't be a Dave
Ramsey they would just be a person that
had no idea where their moral code came
from I know where my moral code comes
from I don't always do it perfectly but
I at least know what it is and I know
what the source of it is and that gives
me a guideline it's a map to the party
baby
it's turn left turn right you missed
your turn turn around and go back you
got to have a map to the party or you're
not getting to the party and that's your
moral code that causes you to make your
decisions what you believe causes you to
make your decisions and the you know
knowledge is a part of your belief
system but most people when it comes to
money already know they need to live on
less than they make and they ought to
have a written plan most people know
running up a bunch of debt is not going
to cause anything but problems most
people know that buying a bunch of stuff
to impress people you don't even like
with a bunch of money that you don't
even have
is a bad idea most people know these
things but what you do then flows out of
your belief system so I spend all my
time on the radio the podcasts the
YouTube I spend all my time on stage I
spent all my time writing books and
doing curriculum for a Financial Peace
University and so on trying to change
your beliefs because once I changed your
beliefs
I've changed your behaviors and that's
how your life gets transformed when you
say Dave you changed my life
I didn't you changed your life I just
showed you how